nutritionists measured the sugar content
in grams for 32 drinks at Starbucks a
cumulative relative frequency graph let
me underline that a cumulative relative
relative frequency graph for the data is
shown below so they have different on
the horizontal axis different amounts of
sugar in grams and then we have the
cumulative relative frequency so let's
just make sure we understand how to read
this this is saying that zero or zero
percent of the drinks have a sugar
content have no sugar content this right
over here this data point this looks
like it's at the point 5 grams and then
this looks at looks like it's at zero
point one this says that zero point one
or I guess we'd say 10% of the drinks
that that Starbucks offers has 5 grams
of sugar or less this data point tells
us that a hundred percent of the drinks
at Starbucks has 50 grams of sugar or
less the cumulative relative frequency
that's what we for each of these points
we say this this is the frequency that
has that much sugar or less and that's
why it just keeps on increasing and
increasing as we add more sugar we're
going to see we're going to see a larger
proportion or larger relative frequency
has that much sugar or less so let's
read the first question an iced coffee
has 15 grams of sugar estimate the
percentile of this drink to the nearest
whole percent so iced coffee has 15
grams of sugar which would be right over
here and so let's estimate the
percentile so we can see they actually
have a data point right over here and we
can see that 20 percent or 0.2 20
percent of the drinks that Starbucks
offers has 15 grams of sugar or less so
the percentile of this drink if I were
to estimate it it looks like it's the
relative frequency 0.2 has that much
sugar or less and so this percentile
would be 20 percent once again another
way to think about it to read this you
could
these two percentages you could say that
20% has this much sugar or less 15 grams
of sugar or less so an iced coffees in
the 20th percentile let's do another
question so here we are asked to
estimate the median of the distribution
of drinks hint think about the 50th
percentile so the median if you were to
line up all of the drinks you take the
middle drink and so you could view that
as well what drink is or exactly at the
50th percentile so now let's look at the
50th percentile would be a cumulative
relative frequency of 0.5 which be right
over here on our vertical axis another
way to think about it is 0.5 or 50% of
the drinks are going if we go to this
point right over here what has a
cumulative relative frequency of 0.5 we
see that we are right at looks like this
is 25 grams so one way to interpret this
is 50% of the drinks have less than or
have 25 grams of sugar or less so this
looks like a pretty good estimate for
the median for the middle data point
so the median is approximately 25 grams
that half of the drinks have 25 grams or
less of sugar let's do one more based on
the same data set so here were asked
what is the best estimate for the
interquartile range of the distribution
of drinks so the interquartile range we
want to figure out well what's sitting
at the 25th percentile and we want to
think about what's at the 75th
percentile and then we want to take the
difference that's what the interquartile
range is so let's do that
so first the 25th percentile we'd want
to look at the cumulative relative
frequency so 25th this would be 30th so
25th would be right around here and so
it looks like the 25th percentile is
that looks like about I don't know and
we're estimating here so that looks like
it's about
this would be 15 looks like I would say
maybe 18 grams so approximately 18 grams
so once again one way to think about it
is 25% of the drinks have 18 grams of
sugar or less now look at the 75th
percentile so this is 70th 75th would be
right over there
actually I can draw a straighter line to
that I have a line tool here so 75th
percentile would put me right over there
I don't know that looks like I'll go
with 39 grams roughly 39 grams and so
what's the difference between these two
well the difference between these two it
looks like it's about 21 grams so our
interquartile range that our estimate of
our interquartile range looking at the
cumulative relative frequency
distribution because we're saying hey
look it looks like the 25th percentile
looks like 25% of the drinks have 18
grams or less 75% of the drinks have 39
grams or less if we take the difference
between these two quartiles this is the
first the first quartile this is our
third quartile we're going to get 21
grams now if we look at this choice the
choices right over here 20 grams
definitely seems like the best estimate
closest to what we were able to estimate
based on looking at this cumulative
relative frequency graph